the picture that they face tonight jess
is a pitcher who might not be in the
game for too long this is we think the
twins don't like to talk about strategy
all that freely but this is essentially
an opener for minnesota tonight and if
the soccer score early they are hard to
catch in particular with tim anderson if
he gets it done there is victory at the
end the 2-2
from the 24 year old bo burroughs from
texas says anderson pulls it to left and
what a way to start just like yesterday
at wrigley for tim anderson
one of the things about tim anderson is
that he has become a very smart hitter
he gets a fastball
he just opens his hips he explodes on it
and takes it out of the ballpark the
young man
is starting to get his rhythm
it's this one well to center
cave looks up and jimenez does it again
how's this for a first inning it is
three-nothing socks in minnesota
it's an absolute pleasure to watch the
ball just explode off his bat he is so
enormously strong he doesn't appear to
swing hard
but the ball
just rockets off the bat
opposite way and a base knock for brian
goodwin into the gap as larnick cuts it
off goodwin speeds towards second and
slides in safely they are an offensive
machine
and it's only going to get better with
the presence of the man you're looking
at played 25 games earlier this year
just turned 24 years old last tuesday
swings at the second pitch and pops it
up and miguel cido cannot hang on to it
goodwin scores and it is four-nothing
white sox in the first this is
should be the easy third out of the
inning it's not lucas giolito on for his
23rd start his era a touch under four
145 strikeouts in 129 innings that's
good left-handers haven't done much with
him he's facing a bunch of them here
tonight here it is on the one two and he
got him swinging so the first k for g
alito and there's two down in the first
elloy was just born to hit he's as
simple as that
and he tags this one to left down the
line into the corner and that ball is
gone
a three-run shot for eloy jimenez he's
gone deep twice in the first two innings
look it's seven to nothing
and
all eloy has done is hit two home runs
and driven in five runs giolito's 2-1
snow in the center
robert comes in on it and he makes the
catch
presents it and hangs on for out number
two okay so the first play that luis had
and again he's a gold glove center
fielder this one fooled him a bit
this is paul that hernandez reaches up
to make the catch and help out giolito
o2 is cut out and missed and a strikeout
for giolito
3-2
caught on and missed 96 on the fastball
for gia lito
luis robert goes first pitch swinging in
the right center and cave cannot make
the catch
monkana races around third
throw to the plate is cut off and the
socks add on here in the fifth inning
thanks to luis robert hit the ball very
hard last time but lined it right at
larnick in left field and this time cave
just doesn't get a good break on it and
leading eight nothing on the twins as
lucas giolito gets a comebacker that
clips him
and moncada has no play and hopefully
lucas is all right off the bat of luis
horiz
2-2-2 sano is pulled left side monkatta
up with it hernandez's turn and steve
you're on the money again five four
three well good sliders i mean for cena
was a deadpool hitter if you keep this
ball down you keep it middle out he's
going to try to pull the ball anyway
instead of going to right field and it
cost him a double play lucas appears to
have it now
his 2-2
goes back to the fastball in the shift
the throw on the first to get cave and
that is very nicely done
by
excellent change up to larnick and
strikeout number five for gia lito the
straight change has come to him as he's
moved along he's starting to feel real
good with it
waiting on another 2-2 here it is
cut on him
another excellent change from giolino
who punches out back to that twins
go to end the opposite way with larnick
backpedaling to make the catch and
that'll get abreu home
a sac fly from brian goodwin and it is
nine nothing sucks here in the seventh
pitch
line to left base hit as tim anderson
lines one in the left and then larnick
bobbles as garcia scores
and the sox have hit double figures here
at target field
right center and cave with a diving
catch
jk with a great catch in the gap
for round number one laying out to take
a hit away from hernandez down here snow
and the twins are on the board
screamer into the second deck by cino
his 19th home run of the year watch this
slider just kind of stay right there in
the inside middle
ball just doesn't bite down and away as
hard and starts off inside
on top of that and it just settles right
in the swing plane of cenote so nobody
aboard for johann moncada
tags this one to center with cave back
and there's some hard contact
straight away center for johann moncada
and another sox home run
dominant tonight in minneapolis so this
is a night he'll look back on and look
at these at-bats and realize he might
have found something because he's been
on just about everything tonight
mentioned bummer the last dozen or so
for crochet
the era in the mid twos and on the
second pitch larnick to left laori there
went away
a couple of fast balls from crochet and
then he goes to the nasty slider to
strike out ref snyder two
down here comes the 2-2
cut on in this and the sox win it in
dominant fashion in the opener against
the twins pretty much dominated this
ball game so a good way to start the
series mike you did just a great job